you know i have to tell you you can tell
my set is different if you're watching
this show right now
i am out of california i am in
beautiful tennessee i am breathing the
sweet air of freedom
it's very very nice i miss my friends
and that's it okay i i do not miss
california
not at all so you remember gavin newsom
we covered this on the show
maybe yesterday gavin newsom
broke his own mandates he broke his own
lockdown rules
he told everyone you can't go out you
can't go to restaurants wear the mask
all the time
he shows up to his buddy's birthday
party at french laundry which is an
extraordinarily expensive michelin rated
restaurant
something like 350 or 400 a plate
i looked if you want to add the ricotta
gnocchi the little
a little dish of ricotta gnocchi it's
like a 150 up charge
okay it is uh it's a nice restaurant and
gavin newsom didn't want to miss out on
this party so he goes and he thought the
cameras were off and he got caught
just like so many leftists have nancy
pelosi goes and gets her hair cut
all these other guys chris cuomo goes on
a run in the hamptons when he pretends
that he's
holding up in his basement and he's
going on a run he's going on a bike ride
he gets into a fight with a guy
they're all just lying to you all of
these people and then he gets caught
and he makes an apology that i was
listening very carefully
and for the first almost minute of it i
couldn't discern any
actual apology a few weeks ago
i was asked to go to a friend's 50th
birthday
uh my wife and i friend that i've known
for almost 20
years and uh and a friend that had
invite well put a lot of
time and energy into his 50th birthday
it was in napa which was in the orange
status relatively loose compared to some
other counties
it was to be an outdoor uh restaurant
and we started the well the program
started four o'clock it was one of those
early
reservations i got there a little bit
late at 4 30
and as soon as i sat down at the larger
table i realized it was a little larger
group
than i had anticipated uh and i made a
bad mistake
okay hold on there it is what was the
time what time did you have
i had 44 seconds of excuses
before he even started to intimate
that he had done anything wrong which by
the way he didn't ultimately say
he said i made a mistake but he didn't
make a mistake he chose to violate his
own orders
he chose to be a giant hypocrite he
chose to go to his buddy's birthday
party at the really nice restaurant so
it's not a mistake it's not an accident
like whoopsie daisy
oh no the french laundry fell down in
front of me i guess i'll eat the ricotta
gnocchi
whoops oh no oh my mouth is open and the
delicious regular yucky you're falling
in no you chose to go
and you then give 44 look my friend
we've been friends for a long time so
that you know that makes it okay
and look he put a lot of time and effort
into his birthday not like your idiot
friends i mean
those you're lazy stupid friends they
would and by the way your friends
couldn't even afford the french laundry
so you don't really
it's just different you don't really get
it so i got there got there a little bit
late you know i'm pretty busy on the
governor and everything
and i saw look there are a few more
people but it's like come on it's my
buddy's birthday and i want to do it and
i'm i'm the ruler of california and i
don't have to play by the same rules
that i make everybody else follow
you know i made a mistake so then
he explains his mistake instead of
sitting down i should have
stood up and walked back got in my car
and drove back
to my house instead i chose to sit there
with my wife
and a number of other couples that were
outside the household and you can
quibble about the guidelines et cetera
et cetera but the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time uh
was contradicted and i got to own that
and so i want to apologize to you
hold up stop it no so you're not
apologizing at all
because even when you say i made a
mistake which is not true it wasn't a
mistake it was very intentional
you say look and we get there i was
sitting there with some people and look
really i mean you could quibble about
the guidelines because like
see actually i didn't i didn't really
violate them i think i mean but look we
can let's we can quibble
okay you you can have your view i can
have my view will agree to disagree no
you can't quibble buddy you broke the
rules
you had the rules that said you couldn't
go to that restaurant with all those
many people all together from different
households
you you made those rules and then you
broke them so i'm not going to quibble
about anything
you just want to hold your constituents
to a completely different standard
than you will hold yourself to because
you wanted those delicious gnocchi
at french laundry no quibbling
whatsoever
she says yeah i shouldn't look okay and
so i apologize good apologize please
give me the apology are we gonna get an
apology
i need to preach and practice not just
preach and not practice and i've done my
best to do that
we're all human we all fall short
sometimes
we've been out i think for three times
since in fact
i know it's been three times because i
remember all of those dinners very very
vividly
since february just three times twice
with my wife by myself
outdoors and then this one occasion with
a larger group and there were just a few
extra people there uh then the spirit of
what
i am promoting oh it's not even an
apology
you're just trying to get ahead of the
story that's inevitably going to come
out that you've broken your own
guidelines other times as well
that's what this has been because yeah
and look okay i did it i made a mistake
i have to i know probably i've done it a
couple other times too
um what was that governor newsome no
yeah no it's really i know i'm going to
keep smiling and it's all a day look
it's kind of a big misunderstanding
but yeah for a while now i've been
disregarding the rules that i'm making
you all follow and
i know that maybe there's a chance some
journalist is going to cover this so
because the sacramento bee's really
angry at me so yeah i've done it a few
times but look hey you know everyone
makes mistakes okay can we move on can
we move past this please
hahaha and i think i still am waiting
for the
the real apology to come in and he just
closes his message to the people
smiling and so if we're going to
minimize mixing you got to
got to own up to that so i just want
folks to know that
paid for our dinner uh and we uh you
know
we had an early dinner but didn't matter
i shouldn't have been there
i should have turned back around and uh
so when that happens
you gotta you pay the price but you also
own the mistake and you don't ever make
it again
and you have my word on that and you
have my word okay you gotta pay the
price i
obviously i don't i'm not going to pay
any price and i'm not even really
admitting i did anything wrong it was an
early dinner you know it wasn't a late
dinner and i paid my way by the way
hey if any of you ethics researchers are
looking into this i paid for my dinner
even though they're
they're definitely lobbyists there but
anyway it's all a big misunderstanding
you gotta take ownership
which i will never ever do i'm governor
newsom
goodbye does he look sorry does he sound
sorry to you no
not at all did chris cuomo sound sorry
no he didn't sound sorry at all when he
lied about quarantining with coronavirus
and he didn't actually quarantine
he went outside and then he lied about
it then he filmed this whole ridiculous
charade
of him coming out of his basement for
the first time he wasn't coming out for
the first time
in weeks and seeing his family he had
been out and about
on long island so much so that he got
into a fight with a guy in the street
nancy pelosi did nancy pelosi apologize
when she got caught going to that
hairdresser without a mask
in violation of the lockdown orders no
she actually blamed the hairdresser do
you remember that i said oh this was a
setup i shouldn't have go i can't
believe she did that to me
no lady you broke your own rules what do
you mean her fault own up to your
mistake
dr fauci same thing even dr fatchy a
little less so it was a little less
publicized how many times did that guy
get caught without a mask on
after he told all of us that we have to
have our masks on after he told all of
us that none of us can have our masks on
none of these guys pay a price for any
of it
why because conservatives are not
ruling the country even when it's trump
even when
the republicans have both houses of
congress and the presidency
conservatives are not ruling this
country ever
the left rules this country i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you